à quelques kilomètres de strasbourg dans
les locaux de biosynex entreprise de
santé publique
une intense activité se prépare ici on
va avoir la nouvelle machine qui va
pouvoir vraiment nous permettre de faire
plus de trois mille tests à l'heure et
l'ancienne machine va arriver ici donc
l'une avec l'autre plus le manuel on
peut arriver facilement à plus de cinq
milles à l'heure comme des centaines
d'entreprises en france cet acteur
majeur de la santé nés en 2005 a décidé
de relocaliser une partie de ces
filières
jusqu'ici basés en chine où plus fort de
la crise sanitaire cette entreprise de
180 personnes a dû en embaucher 70 face
à la pénurie des matières premières et
des produits finis qui venaient de chine
nous avons regardé quels étaient les
produits que nous pourrions rien dû se
régler et relocaliser en france et le
choix s'est porté sur des produits à
haute technicité et haute valeur ajoutée
et donc pour pouvoir rivaliser avec ses
productions asiatiques
il a fallu plutôt miser sur des produits
pour lesquels la part de main d'oeuvre
il était un peu plus faible et la part
de matières premières et de valeur
ajoutée plus importantes comme la
production des tout nouveaux tests
antigénique pour dépister le coc vie
dans 15 minutes autorisé seulement
depuis le 18 octobre et vont être une
arme supplémentaire pour dépister le coc
vide une arme rapide surtout et facile
d'emploi pour les pharmaciens en
particulier mais aussi à destination
d'autres professionnels qui pourront
faire ces prélèvements lors de la crise
sanitaire les failles de la france pays
le plus d industrialisés d'europe avec
seulement 2,7 milliards d'emplois dans
ce secteur ont été révélés les enjeux de
souveraineté de compétitivité ont été
étalées au grand jour
face à cette question stratégique le
gouvernement a réservé un milliard sur
les sens du plan de relance
spécifiquement aux aides directes pour
les relocalisations les relocalisations
joue pour nous
un rôle fondamental d'abord parce que
c'est montrer qu'il n'ya pas de fatalité
et c'est bâtir sur des secteurs d'avenir
comme en particulier le secteur
pharmaceutique les fonds accordés
bénéficieront aux productions de quatre
autres secteurs électronique matière
première essentielle à l'industrie
applications industrielles de la 5g et
agroalimentaire mais selon une
chercheuse spécialisée dans le domaine
de l'entreprise les aides ne ferons pas
tout pour aider l'entreprise à
relocaliser ou pour ancrer durablement
les entreprises sur le territoire
français ce qu'il faut à mon avis et
développer des mesures en faveur du
développement de l'activité économique
et c'est pas uniquement des mesures
fiscales
à partir du moment où vous avez on dit
un maquereau 1 environ environnement
mais un environnement où vous avez la
main d'oeuvre qualifiée vous avez un
bassin d'emploi vous avez des facilités
d'installation
c'est autant de raisons qui vous
conduire l'entreprise à développer une
production en france trois mille six
cents dossiers d'entreprises de demande
de financement d'une ligne de production
en france ont été déposés selon une
annonce du gouvernement le 20 octobre
enjeu est de taille le grand cabinet de
conseil pwc a en effet identifié 58
produits importés qui coûtent 115
milliards à la france par an si 20% de
ces produits étaient fabriqués en france
il pourrait créer 75 mille emplois
attaqué par l'opposition sur les failles
de souveraineté les fermes mesures d'
usine
le gouvernement devra négocier
soigneusement ce virage